la doctrine est extrêmement claires les
masques soignants sont réservés aux
soignants et l'état a toujours été clair
sur ce point en particulier pour les
masques ffp2 qui sont réservées aux
actes invasifs et pour tous les
soignants le masque chirurgical
ensuite il y a effectivement aujourd'hui
de plus en plus grâce à la production
française de masques non soignants les
français n'ont jamais porter de masque
dans l'histoire récente
si les français veulent notamment ceux
qui sont exposés notamment les
professionnels qui ont des activités de
contacts dans lesquelles ils ne peuvent
pas garder la distance ou dans lesquels
ne peuvent pas éviter les rassemblements
disposer de masquer ce sera un outil de
plus mais je rappelle et c'est très
important que le jour où il y aura des
confinement qui n'est pas arrivé il y
aura de toute façon à garder les mesures
barrières les mesures de distanciation
sociales la réduction des contacts et il
ne faut surtout pas imaginer que le
masque et la remet une larme unique
d'ailleurs vous savez que les débats
scientifiques se poursuivent ce n'est
pas un débat de la dgs aux dhimmis à la
santé c'est un débat aux états unis
c'est un débat en europe et sa taille
bas au sein de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
le directeur général de l'ade de l' oms
doit regagner son modèle de la santé a
même re dit son inquiétude sur le fait
que pour certains
l'accès aux masques pouvait signifier
l'abandon de toutes les autres mesures
barrières et ce serait une erreur donc
il ne faut pas prendre le mas comme une
une assurance contre le virus puisque je
vous rappelle qu'il se transmet par les
mains souillées par des objets souillés
d'où l'importance de se laver les mains
très régulièrement qui se transmet par
un contact au cours duquel on ne fait
pas attention et on peut se contaminer
notamment en se touchant le visage et
donc il faut qu'on soit tous attentifs à
bien différencier les masques soignants
qui sont en priorité pour les soignants
le masque p2 le masque chirurgical
et puis un jour peut-être un accès à des
masques que la france est en train de
produire qui sont des masques destinés à
des non soignants et dont on verra tous
ensemble la doctrine d'utilisation